hyper ton adderall non ma marque de pote Hé
salut je suis Nikki c'est sam bon oh mon dieu
Paris Hilton c'est Kirsten Dunst je
pense juste que nous voulions faire partie du
style de vie que tout le monde
veut en quelque sorte je peux être la réponse je  Je suis prêt
à danser quand le Paris Hilton organise
une soirée à Vegas ce soir pourquoi a-t-elle
aimé pensez-vous que nous pourrions trouver un moyen d'
entrer je ne sais pas allez allons à Paris
je veux voler j'étais dans le 212 sur le
Uptown Austin quoi de neuf La vie de Raquel
quelle est une jolie robe pour obtenir n'importe quelle robe nous
avions tellement de belles choses
s'il vous plaît regardez c'est chaud j'entends des hélicoptères
nous sommes à LA ne sois pas si petite garce
tu me stresses la police
enquête  la connexion des
cambriolages d'Hollywood Hills L'Amérique a
cette fascination malade pour un
genre de Bonnie et Clyde tout revient à comme de
mauvais choix qui vous avez est votre téléphone
ne peut pas prendre son chien mais il m'aime bien
Je suis un croyant ferme en  karma et je pense que
la situation est une énorme leçon d'apprentissage
pour moi de grandir et de m'épanouir en tant qu'être humain spirituel,
je veux quitter le pays
un jour pour tout ce que je sais, a-t-il parlé à l'
une des victimes dont j'ai parlé avec
moi, vraiment qu'a dit Lindsay